(street noise)
- Should be a great day.
On my way to
breakfast with Beth Comstock.
One of the most
senior executives at GE.
She's a real innovator.
Always has a pulse on where
things are going, you know?
Actually in a lot of ways
connect with her as an executive
and a businessperson.
Think she has a tremendous
balance of caring about what's
emerging and what's popping,
3-D printing, social media,
virtual reality, online video.
Just whatever really.
She's been at the forefront for
a big company of being early and
often in tasting it,
while also in my
opinion always being
grounded in it actual
practicality of business.
I think it's that the 80/20
rule that I'm proud of that I do
which is
which is 80%
meat and potatoes,
80% meat and potatoes,
you know?
Run the agency,
make money, sell wine
in the store, online
but innovate.
20% real 20%.
Real. Not half-ass it like really
Musically, Anchor, figuring out
Snapchat long before the ROI is
obvious but making those bets to
where the puck is gonna go.
And having a real cadence
not letting them become 90/10.
Not letting it become 70/30.
One man's point of view on
how to be very successful
in a modern world.
I think that goes
extremely well.
How did you feels about
yesterday's DailyVee?
- [DRock] Light but
it was pretty good.
- Light?
- [DRock] But good.
- Fire away, Craig.
Fire away.
People asking me what
happened to Mike my trainer
if something happened.
Nothing happened.
We just ran our
two-year contract out.
Two years every
day of your life.
On somebody else's schedule, on
every whim and need that they
want that's a tough grind.
So Mike did an amazing
job and I miss him dearly.
He still around
for another month.
But Jordan and I are starting
our cadence and our system and
away we go.
Three years for Jordan.
Next guy is four.
I think the Share Bear
is stunningly important.
And it's going to
become a thing.
Like other people are going to
copy and this is going to become
a thing that Facebook's
going to respond to.
- [DRock] Really?
- I think so.
There's this quote that
people are going crazy for.
- [DRock] Where
is that one from?
Do you know?
- Snapchat.
- [DRock] Yesterday?
- Yep. If you lack
optimism, it's game over.
- [DRock] It's a good one.
- It's true.
- [DRock] Oh, without a doubt.
- [Gary] It's just true.
If you can't look
for the bright side or
look at the half glass full
or be optimistic instead of
pessimistic if you can't do that
you just absolutely have no
chance in winning because it's
all how one synthesizes
what's in front of them.
You know what I mean?
Life's hard enough, the game is
hard enough, the market is hard
enough against you that if
you're against yourself
that's too stacked.
The deck becomes too stacked.
About to go on Facebook Live
for an episode of #AskGaryVee.
Go check it now. Now.
Speed in which Snapchat is
innovating it's product is
grossly underestimated as
one of the rationales to
it's hypergrowth.
People don't get it.
That shit matters.
From a branding perspective
and a product perspective.
Hello.
- [Group] Hello.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this episode 208 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
And this is a very, very,
very special episode of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Using it and then commentating
on it you will create a much
bigger awareness funnel and then
people are like, "Oh, I want to
"use that girl, that guy.
"They're good at Snapchat,
Instagram and wedding photos."
- [Woman] Hi.
- Hello.
(laughter)
Nice hair bro.
- Thanks.
- Did a good job.
What you guys doing?
- [Group] Status.
- Love it. There's lot of you.
Yeah.
(laughter)
No.
Oh, yes, yes.
Good job, Avi.
I didn't even know.
How is it going?
Good morning, how
are you my friend?
Good.
(light music)
That game.
Alright, I gotta go, love you.
Doctor.
I was literally laying there for
like 10 minutes like do you know
what's crazy man?
And this is not a joke.
It actually ended up being a
great moment I literally sat
there and you know how I
get, I'm like I'm gonna die.
I was pretty pumped with the way
it all played out I'm like all
right, you know?
Sup? Yep.
No, that was not a fun moment.
I don't think they're going to
come and there's Playa sounds
like he's gonna come for a
night for the play tennis.
You too, love you.
Love you, muah. Bye.
Dude.
- Oh sorry.
- Andy I'll call you right back.
- You're detached.
- It's alright, I know.
Alright. Bye.
- Dude.
- What's up man?
- How are you?
- I'm like half asleep.
- How's it going?
- Good.
What's going on?
- Things are good.
- You look good.
You look really good.
- Two years of working
out every day adds up.
So glad we ran into
each other brother.
Love you.
Say hi to Lisa.
- Yes, I will and to Liz.
We haven't seen her in forever.
- Hey.
How are you?
How's it going?
I'll see you soon.
How you doing?
- He said he went with you.
- Yes, how you feeling?
- Good.
- I heard my mom
told me the other day.
- Oh my god, I'm running
around like a crazy person.
- It's a girl right?
- It's a girl. Yeah,
thanks for knowing. So nice.
- Yeah. We're talking about it.
- I work right here.
- Is that right?
- How are you?
You're probably so busy?
Crazy?
- Super busy.
- That's awesome.
My brother watches
you all the time too.
- Is that right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good to see you.
- Glad we ran into each other.
Say hi for me.
- I will.
- It's 11:51 in the morning it's
been an eventful as fuck, right?
Just a lot of shit going on.
Wow.
Okay, bye.
- Hey, Gary, man it's a pleasure
to see you in person.
I love your videos.
- What's your name?
- Arain.
- Arain, nice to meet you.
51 and five.
- [DRock] 53rd.
- [Gary] Hey Al.
- [Tyler] Feeling good?
- [Gary] Feeling great.
- [Claude] Yes.
- Hello Claude.
- How are you?
Are you on the right angle?
- [DRock] I am.
We're good here.
- I missed you.
- Close the door.
(hip hop music)
Facebook Live stuff gets
people's panties in a bunch.
- [Zak] It does.
It really does.
- Well it's 50-50.
- It's just the worst.
It's the worst phrase.
- Right, you are mad that
they actually got upset.
You get mad about.
- It's that phrase.
- You do know that that phrase
would've been long gone if you
didn't make a big deal about it.
You're the single reason
it's still around and
may never go away.
Ever.
- [Emily] So bad.
- [Gary] Everybody, you know.
I'm almost perfect for you
so I got to have something.
Yeah.
You got a haircut?
- [Alex] I did.
- It looks great.
- Thanks man.
Doesn't grow like it used to.
- Listen, you're preaching.
Yeah.
- Cool.
- Cool. Thanks.
- [Gary] Marcus. Marcus.
- Yeah, I know, it's not good.
- Are you all right?
- Yeah.
- It's devastating.
- I know, it's tough.
It sucks.
I actually like--
- You're very upset.
- Yeah, I'm upset about it.
It's fine.
I mean it sucks and logically it
was so much better than what
I could've expected going
in but from being of--
- Being up 3-1--
- Exactly, exactly.
- Being a real Thunder fan.
- But Durant's going to stay.
- Is that true?
- There's almost no
way he's going to leave.
- Is that true?
- Yeah.
The only place
doesn't want to be--
- In Washington?
- That's one place
he actually said
almost every source is like
there's no change he goes there.
He doesn't want to go back home,
no player wants to go back home.
- Does he want to be
the Jets quarterback?
- He actually would
do that actually.
- Yeah, course brother.
- Awesome.
- Thanks for the kind words man.
- Absolutely man.
- Real pleasure.
- Love it.
- Thank you.
(light music)
Love it.
- How you do?
- How are you, man?
It's good to see you.
I haven't seen
you in a long time.
Oh God, it's so nice.
- Yeah.
- Did you get the invite for?
Dude.
Oh, right.
I forgot.
I actually completely forgot.
I'm in with these guys.
Thanks for that note.
- Yeah.
- Are you going to be up
there or are you gone?
- No, I'm leaving.
See you soon.
- Are you going
out this weekend?
- Probably not.
- Okay. But baseball, right?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Maybe DRock will come.
Thank you.
- [Man] I just want
to pull up the doc.
I really want to talk to
you about the ICC pitch.
- Sure.
(piano music)
- [Gary] It's, um,
it's victim syndrome.
It's just if I could just figure
out if I can just figure out
how to it's honestly probably
the thing I think it's so funny.
I so value the practical
advice that I give to people.
And the live by example like
forget about what I say this is
what I'm doing.
That's why DailyVee is so
important and Snapchat.
But no question, no question the
thing that I am now six months
into this kind of zone am
realizing is being the beacon of
hope and optimism and
looking at the bright side.
The thing that I've done for
the 20 people closest to me that
center of energy that you can
rely on even when it is crappy
is going to think it is great
I'm scaling that through my
content right now.
That's the emails that are
hitting me in my soul which is
like you've given me
permission to dream.
The energy that I have inside
figure out how to scale that
to give people that
optimism that half glass full.
And then the practicality, the
realist of it I and nobody's
going to care.
You can do it but
nobody's gonna care.
That thing is,
the thing that I least
get excited about because
very motivation but
I thing that I can't avoid
is bringing value
to so many people.
And it's important.
It's important.
If I can ever get
the world
and this is such a
ludicrous statement.
If I can get the world to
see the world through my eyes.
It would be Nirvana.
And since I know I can't do that
I feel obligated to everybody
who's watching right now,
I feel obligated, DRock.
Honestly, I feel obligated to
the people that have rewarded me
with their number one asset which
is their attention and time to
work as hard as I can to try
to give them that olive branch.
Of seeing the world through my
eyes for just an hour, for just
a second, through just one
quote, through four seconds of
video through a 30 minute
episode if they can see the
world through my eyes
they would be so
grateful and happy.
Shit is deep.
True as fuck.
- Good to see you.
- [Gary] Pleasure, brother.
- How are you?
- Oh, sorry, bro.
Looking forward to this.
Alright, DRock time
to go home and edit.
Me and see and CF-Bro
have got big boy talk.
- It's the best, man.
(light music)